jjuu kaisen Yu-Gi-Oh cards are now a
thing and in this video I'm going to
explain how the deck works and where you
can get it for yourself what's going on
people so recently I was sent these
Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen and Attack on Titan
Yu-Gi-Oh cards in the post and as a
massive fan of both series and a fan of
the original Yu-Gi-Oh anime and a fan of
Yu-Gi-Oh GX this is basically the best
thing ever for today we're going to
focus on the jjk deck cuz these cards do
work really well together but if you
haven't played Yu-Gi-Oh for a long time
don't worry I will be explaining any new
Concepts that have appeared in like
recent Years cuz I have been playing a
little bit of mass duel myself so so
I've managed to kind of catch up with a
lot of things that have been happening
in the Yu-Gi-Oh World okay so as you
might expect from a deck full of
sorcerers most of these cars have
effects that involve sending something
to the graveyard which is just another
way of saying exercising curses for
example when we look at Yuji the main
character his main effect is that when
you summon him you can send any c C
monster directly from your deck to the
grave and I'll give you a demonstration
of how we can use this to eventually
summon suca all right so the first thing
we're going to do is normal summon Yuji
to the field and by doing that it
activates his first effect which is what
I just mentioned so now we can kind of
look through the deck and find any
monster that has cursed in its name and
send that to the graveyard and in this
situation I'm going to pick mahito
partly because they're mortal enemies
but also because maho's effect is pretty
useful in this situation if we look at
the whole picture mahito does actually
have two effects but for now the main
one we care about is his second effect
which says that you can banish this card
from your graveyard and special summon
any cursed monster from your deck what
that means is that by removing him from
the grave and putting him in this little
uh banish Zone here we can look through
the deck again and basically pick any
cursed monster so in this case I'm going
to pick Joo cuz he is the strongest
cursed monster that exists in the main
deck and he has an attack of 2,300 for a
card that has five stars 2,300 is pretty
good actually and it's a lot higher than
Yuji for example like if you look at
yuji's attack he only has 1,800 which
for a monster of his level four stars
you know 1,800 is very good but Joo is
just like that next level above him I
mean he is special grade also one small
detail that I appreciated with this is
that when you look at jogo his attribute
is fire which makes perfect sense
obviously when we look at mahito his
attribute is darkness which again is
perfect because I mean he is like the
most evil Cur Spirit he just goes around
killing people willy-nilly um so I feel
like Darkness represents his personality
very well anyhow just like that we have
two relatively strong monsters on the
field and this is where Yugi's second
effect comes into play so it says here
that by paying 500 life points you can
special summon sukus cursed finger from
your hand deck or graveyard as you can
see sukus cus finger is a really weak
monster it has zero attack only 1,000
defense and it's a normal monster which
is something you don't usually see in
Yu-Gi-Oh nowadays back in the day normal
monsters used to be very common they're
basically monsters that don't have
special effects by itself it obviously
can't do that much but with Yuji here
you can basically perform a contact
fusion with these two cards which is
basically merging them together and
sending them to the graveyard and once
we do that we can directly summon suca
from our extra deck generally speaking
the extra deck is where you keep all of
your strongest monsters and they can
only really be summoned in certain
situations like this and when it comes
to sua his attack is 2,800 which is the
second highest out of all of the
Jiu-Jitsu kaisen cards I think most of
you can probably guess that the number
one strongest character is Gojo who has
an attack of 3,000 I would say though
even though Gojo's card technically has
more Firepower than sua what I didn't
mention is that sukina has a special
ability that immediately increases his
attack points that effect says that once
per turn you can send one cursed monster
from your deck to the graveyard and this
card will gain attack equal to that
Monster's attack until the end of the
turn an example of what that would look
like is if we search through the deck
for someone to sacrifice in this case
I'm going to pick Megami so if suo was
to sacrifice Megami and send him to the
Grave then he would gain all of megami's
attack points for the rest of the turn
and in this case Megami has 1,600 attack
so that would increase suk's attack
points from 2,800 to 4,400 temporarily
making him the strongest card in the
deck also sua's final special ability is
that when his card is summoned to the
field you can Target any card that's in
your banish zone or your graveyard and
you can summon that monster directly to
the field right now the strongest card
that's in the banish zone or the
graveyard is mahito so we're going to
pick him and when mahito himself is
summoned to the field his first effect
activates earlier I mentioned that he
had two effects and his first one
directly relates to his ability in the
show which is to shape the soul of
something something what I mean by that
is that when this card is special
summoned you can basically look at the
top three cards of your own deck add one
of those cards to your hand and then
Shuffle the rest of the deck so you're
reshaping the deck into a completely
different order than it was before in
that sense you are basically reshaping
the soul of your deck if it has a soul
and uh yeah so I really like that
comparison of how reshaping souls in the
show is you know now reshaping the order
of your deck now assuming that your
opponent went first if this was a real
duel you would have began things off
with six cards in your hand and just by
playing Yuji that one card we now have a
boss monster on the field and two pretty
powerful monsters alongside it of course
that's all assuming that your opponent
doesn't negate everything which in
modern Yu-Gi-Oh there are a lot of
negates so uh I guess yeah you wouldn't
really be able to do this in the exact
same way uh however it is interesting to
see the potential of how these cards
work together in fact if we wanted to
continue this combo then we could play
jiujitsu cursed energy which is a
quickplay spell card that has the effect
of basically allowing you to discard any
cursed monster from your hand and once
you do that you can destroy two cards on
the field one has to be a spellow trap
but the other card can be anything it
can be another spellow trap or it can be
a monster as well for the sake of this
example I'm going to discard Dagon the
SE cured spirit and this card has its
own effect when it's sent to the Grave
by discarding Dagon from our hand to our
graveyard we can activate its effect
which says that you can banish this card
from your grave and then special summon
any cursed monster directly from your
hand in a sense it is just a weaker
version of maho's ability to summon
cards directly from the deck um but in
this case we can use it pretty well
because in our hand we have a second
copy of Megami when he's on the field
you can special summon one cursed
shikigami from either your deck or your
hand if we look through the deck now we
can find one pretty easily and you know
similar to suk's finger it's a normal
monster that doesn't really have that
much attack or defense I mean it only
has one dozen attack which isn't very
much at all that being said it will
still be useful later on but before we
get to that I want to show you how we
can summon ghetto to the field if we
look into the extra deck for a second we
can see that ghetto is an XZ monster and
essentially the way you summon It Is by
stacking existing monsters on the field
on top of each other so in this case we
have Joo who's level five and we have
maito who's also level five so if we
stack mahito on top of jogo then they
kind of get like overtaken by ghetto
like you can summon ghetto on top of
them because he is rank five by making
him an XZ it's like they're part of him
which is exactly how his technique Works
he absorbs curses into his body and then
can use their powers whenever he feels
like it anyhow if we take a look at the
text we'll see that there are two
separate effects for ghetto and the main
one is that during either player's turn
you can detach one material from this
card so that would either be mjo or
Drogo you would detach them and send
them to the graveyard and if you do that
you can activate a cursed trap card
straight from the deck if we then scroll
through the deck to find the Trap cards
you'll see that there are four separate
trap card effects in this deck one of
which is a counter trap so we'll talk
about that one first and the name of
this card is cursed punishment and the
effect of it is that when your opponent
activates a monster effect or a trap
card of their own you can negate that
effect and what I love about this card
is that the design is mahara mahar's
main effect is adapting to things and
essentially negating things and so to
have a card that negates monster effects
have mahara representing it you can't
get much better than that the next trap
card is Vengeance of the spirits and
this one essentially Works to negate
your opponent's spell cards but yeah it
does have a couple downsides but overall
I think it is still a good card moving
on to trap number three we have cursed
binding vow and the effect of this card
basically negates the effect of one
monster on the field every turn you can
reuse it as long as you have cursed
monsters on the field so it is pretty
useful finally curse Spirits rebirth is
the last trap card that we have here and
this one is probably the most simple
it's just a trap card that you can
summon and use as a normal monster that
has 1,000 attack and zero defense so
yeah that was a pretty interesting
selection and like I was saying ghetto
effect allows you to activate them
straight from your deck as long as you
know as long as everything on the field
allows that to happen now switching to
Gojo you might be wondering how do we
get him on the field in this situation
cuz if you're an old school Yu-Gi-Oh fan
like me you might not be familiar with
Link monsters Link monsters are these
blue ones that have the arrows around
the frame and it is basically the newest
type of monster in the show and every
single one of them has a thing called a
link rating generally speaking the
stronger the card is the higher the
rating will be hence white Toto has a
rating of one nanami has a rating of two
and Gojo has a rating of four what that
means in this situation is that to
summon Gojo to the field that we have
right here we would have to send all
four monsters to the graveyard naturally
that wouldn't be the smartest thing to
do considering we have you know two boss
monsters right here so what we need to
do is add two extra monsters to the
field if we can do that then Gojo can be
summoned by sacrificing the two new
monsters and meami in the shikami so to
start things off the first thing we
would do is activate ghetto first effect
as we mentioned before this effect
allows us to detach either mahito or
Drogo and by doing that we can summon
cursed Spirits rebirth straight from the
deck by doing that we now have three
monsters who could be sacrificed for
Gojo but we still need one more and this
is where cursed world might come into
play cursed world is a continuous spell
card which means that once you put it on
the field it stays on the field and its
main effect is that by discarding a card
from your hand you can special summon
one cursed monster that's either
banished or in the grave in this example
I'm going to use the card to scard
hanamy so I can summon Joo and now that
we have these two extra monsters on the
field we can link summon Gojo by
sacrificing Cur spirit's rebirth meami
the kers kagami and also joogo who
unfortunately literally just got
summoned in doing that we've now managed
to summon three of the four strongest
cards in the deck the only one missing
is RA but we'll talk more about her
towards the end of the video for now the
main thing I wanted to explain was
Gojo's effects and how his card effects
directly relate to his abilities in the
show for instance the first line here
says that this card is unaffected by
other monster effects which is a nod to
Infinity he's basically impervious to
anything that people can throw at him so
making him unaffected by other monster
effects that is the perfect way to
represent what Infinity is all about
lastly his final effect I think is meant
to be reverse curse technique cuz it
says that if this card inflicts battle
damage to your opponent you can then
special summon one un cursed monster
from your own graveyard which is
essentially bringing them back to life
and as we've seen reverse curse
technique can be used to heal other
people so yeah I guess that's what this
means for the sake of this example let's
say that Gojo does attack and activate
this effect the one monster that I would
pick to summon is hanamy by the way I
think only 1,400 attack is a bit low for
hanamy like he should at least be 2,000
or 2,100 um but let me know in the
comments what you think Han's card says
that when this card is special summon
you can then special summon another
cursed monster that's either banished or
in your graveyard this gives us a great
chance to bring Dagon back into the game
so we're going to put Dagon on the field
like I said in the beginning the deck
works really well together because the
same cards are constantly being recycled
and reused for different purposes and
from that we've been able to get all of
this anyhow there were quite a few cards
that we didn't get to use in that
demonstration um so we're just going to
go through the last of them now and the
first one I want to talk about is domain
expansion the effect of this spell card
is pretty simple it just allows you to
add any cursed card from your deck to
your hand although with a name like
domain expansion I was hoping that it
would be more like I don't know
something that increases the attack or
or increases the effect somehow or you
know something that kind of gives the
cards a boost just cuz that's what
domain expansion is it gives whoever's
using it a boosting power and you know
allows them to truly use their curse
technique to the best of its ability so
for that reason I just I was a little
bit disappointed with this card but it
is what it is moving on the next card is
Toto curse Sorcerer And I really like
this one because the effect of this card
is effectively the exact same as Toto's
actual technique what it does is that
when this card is on the field you can
return any curse monster that you
control into the deck and then you can
take any curse monster from the deck and
put that to the field too's card Effect
also allows you to swap a cursed monster
from your hand and put that into the
deck and then just replace that with any
any card from your deck to your hand so
again it's all about swapping places of
cards on the field or cards in your hand
with cards in your deck now next up we
have ra the Vengeance curse which is the
second strongest card in the deck
alongside suca and we also have otu the
curs sorcerer now these two cards you
can't have one without the other because
ra can only be summoned once aotu is on
the field so aotu has a rank of four
which means that we could summon him by
just having two level four monsters on
the field and then kind of of overlaying
those on top of each other to to summon
aotu and his effect is that you can
detach two materials from him and then
you can summon ra and it's the only way
that R can be summoned once you then
have both of them on the field together
their individual effects work to protect
each other and what I mean by that is
that otu's effect is that when he's on
the field R can't be destroyed by card
effects and Ra's effect is that when
she's on the field aotu can't be
destroyed by battle I honestly love the
the meaning in that because it is true
like as long as aotu has ra how can you
beat him in battle like it can't happen
unless your name is Gojo or sua you're
not going to win the next card is nobara
and just like everyone else her effect
does kind of relay to her curse
technique so what it says here is that
you can discard one card from your hand
and then your opponent is forced to also
discard one card the way I see it this
is meant to be a call back to her straw
doll technique cuz the way that works is
that you get get to hurt your opponent
by attacking something that's not
directly attached to them and so this
effect kind of mirrors that in that
you're discarding one of your own cards
hurting yourself in a way but then by
doing that your opponent is also forced
to take some kind of penalty so there is
a comparison to be made there and in a
deck like this where you can gain an
advantage by sending certain cards to
the graveyard this is a card that you
would want to have nmy the cursed Mentor
is next up and he has an attack of 2,100
which is pretty high considering that
Hanami was 1,400 I mean don't get me
wrong nanami is powerful he is a rock um
but this does seem a little bit High
when you compare it to the special grade
monsters cursed burial is the second
last card and it lets you send a cursed
monster from your deck straight to the
graveyard and cursed ceiling is a
continuous spell card and its effect
here is that you can Target three cursed
cards that are either in your graveyard
or in your banish Zone and by shuffling
them back into your deck you can then
draw an another card so essentially it
allows you to draw an extra card every
turn as long as you have enough monsters
that are either in the grave or just
banished um so yeah it is a solid deck
and I think it would do very well
against cards from the era of Yu-Gi-Oh
that I'm used to you know the GX type
cards Heroes Cyber Dragons that kind of
thing I think it could do well against
them if you're interested in buying
these to play with your friends the name
of the company is oras Yu-Gi-Oh it's an
Instagram page that you can find in the
description and yeah they're the ones
who create these custom cars so from so
many different animes I think there's
others that I haven't mentioned like
fairy tale JoJo's there's a bunch of
stuff and uh the Cs are amazing quality
and I will be using them for sure thanks
for watching as always and until the
next one peace out